my view one of the single most important
things we have to do is to make teaching
a more attractive profession there's a
lot of argument about one piece of this
would pay for performance make teaching
more or less appealing to the to the
people we want to have teaching I think
the jury's out on that but I think it's
fair to say that in general the quality
of the teaching force has taken second
place in the current wrap around it
reforms there's a an edict that we must
somehow have highly qualified teachers
everywhere but how do we get them you
have to convince people to do it first
and you have to convince them not to
leave a lot of people leave teaching
because they find it a very stressful
and unsatisfying role so I think we need
to go back to square one and say since
we know that American education has some
chronic deficiencies what can we say
about the causes of those deficiencies
what can we say about the impediments
that stand in the way of doing better
and when we don't know we ought a good
look we got to go into schools do hard
research to figure out which of the
impediments really matter and then craft
policies that try to chip away at those
impediments instead of doing what we've
done for 30 years which is just make it
up make up a policy drop it on schools
and see what happens or more often than
not fail to see what happens because we
drop these things into schools without
putting in place the kind of monitoring
that kids deserve but in my view it's
not all that surprising that our reforms
haven't been more effective than that
they happen today
you